in this video you're gonna learn how to
find the arcsine arc cosine arctangent
or sine inverse cosine inverse tangent
inverse however you want to say that
using the unit circle we're going to go
through 15 promise here see if you can
do these on your own but the first thing
I want to talk about is when you're
finding the sine inverse and the tangent
inverse you want to make sure that you
find the angle between negative PI over
two and positive PI over two so it's
going to be in these two quadrants right
here now what you don't want to do if
you end up here in the fourth quadrant
you don't want to go all the way around
like that you just want to make it a
negative angle and when you find the arc
cosine or the cosine inverse you're
gonna be restricted from 0 to PI okay
and the reason that is is because if you
look at the sine graph okay see how the
sine graph goes like this that keeps
repeating this would fail the horizontal
line test meaning that the inverse is
not a function
so what mathematicians decided to do is
they decided to restrict it from
negative PI over 2 to positive R to see
just this part of the graph right here
so that it passes that horizontal line
test meaning that when you go to solve
this you're just going to get one
solution otherwise you can keep going
around the circle as many times as you
want it and you could get you know an
infinite number of answers so you can
see we're restricting from negative PI
over 2 to positive PI over 2 also with
tangent see how tangent looks like this
you'll learn how to graph these but see
how it repeats so this would also fail
that horizontal line test meaning that
the inverse is not a function unless we
just restrict it from negative PI over 2
to positive PI over 2 again this puts us
in the first and fourth quadrants over
here to the right now when you look at
cosine again cosine repeats is failing
that horizontal line test unless we
restrict it from 0 to PI so we're just
looking at this part of the graph right
here okay and that's in the first and
second quadrants so let's go through
some examples and then see if you can do
some of these on your own so if we want
to find out what's the sine inverse of
negative square root 3 over 2 what
that's really asking us is sine of what
angle equals a negative square root 3
over 2 so what we can do is we can go to
our unit circle which I'm sure you
probably memorize
now you can check out my mastering the
unit circle video and we'd say to
ourselves where is the sign negative
root three over two now remember sine is
the y coordinate on the unit circle so
we say all right well I can hold it the
Y is negative root 3 over 2 here it's
also negative root 3 over 2 but remember
we're just restricted from negative PI
over 2 to positive PI over 2 so you can
see I'm going negative PI over 3 ok you
don't want to go all the way around like
this just make it a negative angle so
negative PI over 3 is their answer that
first one for number 2 what's the cosine
inverse of negative one meaning cosine
of what angle equals negative one now
remember on the unit circle cosine is
going to be the x-coordinate and
remember where is the x-coordinate
negative 1 that's going to be right here
at pi and remember when we're solving
for the cosine inverse restricted from 0
to pi so you can see the answer here is
going to be just pi for number 3 what do
you think for this one the tangent
inverse of 0 meaning the tangent of what
angle equals 0 remember on the unit
circle tangent is the Y divided by the X
okay so where is the y coordinate
divided by the x coordinate 0 well that
would be here 0 over 1 is 0
ok so this would be at 0 radians or it
could be over here but you can see this
is not in the restricted domain so for
tangent inverse we want to be from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
so it's just going to be 0 radians ok
for number 4 what's the arc sine of
negative 1/2 now see this arc sine or
sine inverse it's just a different way
of writing the same thing this is just
asking a sine of what angle equals
negative 1/2 on this restricted domain
from negative PI over 2 to positive PI
over 2 well remember what we're talking
about sine we're looking for the Y
coordinates negative 1/2 that's going to
be right here at negative PI over 6 ok
let's look at number 5 what's the arc
cosine of negative square root 3 over 2
meaning cosine of what angle equals
negative root 3 over 2 remember cosine
were restricted from 0 to
that's in these first two quadrants
where does cosine equal negative root
three over two that's where the
x-coordinate is negative root three over
two that's going to be at five PI over
six
okay for number six the arctangent of
negative one this is saying tangent of
what angle equals negative one and
remember tangent on the unit circle is
the y-coordinate divided by the x
coordinate so you can see it's going to
be negative one here because anything
divided by itself is one a negative
divided by a positive is a negative one
so this would be negative PI over four
okay
and that's going to be our answer
because remember we restricted from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over
two when we're doing the sine inverse or
tangent inverse what do you think for
number seven what's the sine inverse of
zero meaning sine of what angle equals
zero well sine remember is the
y-coordinate you can see the
y-coordinates going to be zero right
here at zero radians okay how about
number eight the cosine inverse of zero
so cosine of what angle equals zero
cosine on the unit circle is the
x-coordinate the x-coordinate is zero
right here at PI over two and remember
with cosine inverse were restricted from
zero to pi so it's just that one
solution for number nine the tangent
inverse of square root of three okay so
this is saying tangent of what angle
equals square root of three now remember
tangent is a little bit trickier it's
the y-coordinate divided by the
x-coordinate so here you can see tange
is going to be root three at PI over
three coz square root 3 over 2 divided
by 1/2 gives you square root of three so
what do we say that was a PI over three
now what you can do is let's take square
root of three over two divided by 1/2
see if you multiply the numerator and
denominator by to see how those twos
cancel and you just get square root
three over one which is square root of
three for number 10 the arc sine of one
half this is saying sine of what angle
equals one half so remember on the unit
circle sine is the y-coordinate where
does a y-coordinate equal 1/2 right here
at PI over six and again remember
restricted from here to here negative PI
over 2 to positive PI over two so that's
PI over six our cosine of one half
cosine of what angle equals 1/2 cosine
remembers the x-coordinate where as the
x-coordinate and 1/2 from 0 to pi that's
going to be right here at
over three okay number 12 see if you can
do this one our tangent of negative
square root 3 over 3 this is saying
tangent of what angle equals negative
root 3 over 3 or where does the y
coordinate divided by the x coordinate
equal negative root 3 over 3 from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
well that's going to be right here at
negative PI over 6
now the tangent ones tend to be a little
bit tougher okay because you have to
divide the Y by the X but just to show
you here we have negative 1/2 divided by
positive square root 3 over 2 again if
you multiply the numerator and
denominator by to see how those cancel
anything divided by itself to 2 I have a
2 is 1 so that's not changing the value
here of the fraction and we get negative
1 over root 3 and then if you
rationalize that by multiplying the
numerator and denominator by square root
of 3 that gives you negative square root
of 3 over square root of 9 which is 3
for number 13 what's the sine inverse of
negative root 2 over 2 well this is
saying we're where is sine equal to
negative root 2 over 2 from negative PI
over 2 to positive PI over 2 signs the y
coordinate so that's going to be right
here at negative PI over 4 okay two more
cific into these last two we've got
cosine inverse of root 3 over 2
meaning cosine of what angle equals
square root 3 over 2 from 0 to PI this
is where the x coordinate is root 3 over
2 you can see that's going to be right
here at PI over 6 or 30 degrees and the
number 15 Oh tangent inverse of 1 this
is st. tangent of what angle equals 1
remember tangent so Y over X and that's
going to occur right here
because anything divided by itself is 1
so that's going to be PI over 4 so if
you're enjoying my videos subscribe to
the channel and I've got an organized
list of videos on my Barr's math
tutoring website you can check that out
I'll have a link in the description
below within organized list of videos
going through you know typical algebra 2
course as well as a precalculus course
where ever you're learning these
particular concepts I have
broken down by chapter so check that out
I look forward to seeing the future
videos and I'll talk to you soon